what is it that resonates with  conservatives about marjorie taylor  green i think that she just um  just is not afraid of speaking the truth  and not afraid of being politically  quote unquote incorrect what she says is  right i mean do i agree with every  single thing i nobody's black and white  everybody has areas of gray in life life  is gray  but i do think that her courage and most  republicans i hate to say this but most  republicans who've been in  the kind of in the fold for all these  decades and decades in politics they  kind of just  tout the same thing and they're full of  bull  no on my life  um  they're full of  they're just sitting on their you know  in their golden parachute collecting  living for 20 30 years in washington and  they really don't do anything and here  you have these outliers that come in  they do things they're not afraid of  being politically incorrect saying what  the people want to hear